hello freak [ __ ] you know aligned
with the interest of patients or even of
doctors
well the real issue to me that stands
out as an example of that is these
stupid [ __ ] commercials they have for
pharmaceutical drugs where people are
having the best time ever
well you're looking at them and like the
how is this is so deceptive you're
showing me like best-case scenario
grandpa running pushing the bike and the
little kids laughing and everyone's
having the time of their life like oh I
want the time of my life how do I get in
on that until the last fifteen or thirty
seconds which is like just drive me
cause you know Humera yeah where's that
stuff it was for remember she said it's
like 120 grand for that crap yeah I
think and death is a side effect of that
drug death suicidal thoughts contact
your physician he'll tell you a [ __ ]
yourself
wake him up give me some volume on this
so we can hear this I thought I was
doing okay too but I'm not
she's managing people who still have
symptoms of moderate to severe Crohn's
disease in clinical studies the majority
of people on humerus all significant
symptom relief there we achieved
remission tuberculosis serious sometimes
fatal infections and cancers including
lymphoma
have blood liver and nervous system
problems serious allergic reactions and
new or worsening heart failure before
treatment get tested for TB tell your
doctor if you've been to areas where
certain fungal infections are common and
if you've had TB hepatitis B are prone
to infections or have flu-like symptoms
or sores don't start Humira if you have
an infection just managing your symptoms
okay kill it right there
why is that lady so [ __ ] sweet and
cheery what she's talking about eminent
death and the music just does not and
look the woman is on a TV set to like
she's a successful producer on a
television set what a bizarre choice for
like what she does for a living like
watch her will kill the volume but watch
her wander around the office they're
like who the [ __ ] works on a TV show
like this is we're supposed to relate to
this lady how many people work on the
set look at her she's got her folder she
goes and she grabs a cake yeah she
because even though she has something to
do with Crohn's disease what you eat
she's gonna [ __ ] die in an explosive
imploding rectal or get an infection
that would be totally you know not a
threat for you or anyone else but
because they had taken a drug that
globally suppresses their immune system
can kill you yeah that whole thing like
if you you know if you have an infection
don't take it like what aren't those
pretty common the [ __ ] not to get in
fact don't get an infection while you're
taking Humana it's not like do you ever
try to get an infection I mean how do
you not try to get an infection yeah
this but this is what kills me is the
bizarre choice of her being some sort of
a director or producer of a television
show like that we're supposed to relate
what she is so successful maybe yeah
maybe if you take him area you could
also it was another one a bill a fire
that killed night and it was a
antidepressant you give to people that
are suicidal while taking
antidepressants yeah like what yeah hey
yeah let's talk about abilify it's one I
think it's the sixth or seventh most
prescribed drug in the u.s. it's an
anti-psychotic okay so if those two
things don't
resonating there's a reason for that we
don't have that many psychotics in this
country where abilify could be the set
you know he only uses an anti-psychotic
give me some volume let's hear this
struggles with my depression I was
handling it but sometimes she's a
cartoon I've been feeling stuck for a
long time so I talked to my doctor and
she had it abilify to my antidepressant
she said it could help with my
depression and that some people had
symptom improvement as early as one to
two weeks I'm glad I talked to her I
wish I'd done it sooner now I feel more
in control of your depression worsens or
you have unusual changes in behavior or
thoughts of suicide antidepressants can
increase these in children teens and
young adults your elderly dementia
patients taking abilify have an
increased risk of death or stroke or
call your doctor view of high fever
stiff muscles and confusion to address a
possible life-threatening condition or
if you have uncontrollable muscle
movements as these could become
permanent blood sugar has been reported
with the vilifying medicines like it and
in extreme cases can lead to coma or
death all the rates of Sinclar increased
cholesterol weight gain decreases in
white blood cells which can be serious
dizziness and standing seizures trouble
swallowing
and impaired judgment or motor skills
[Music]
take this [ __ ] most of that is telling
when does it start where they're talking
to you cut this segment of the
commercial where the lady comes out the
doctor comes out show where the lady
doctor is because with it that's like
halfway in the lady doctor comes out
just break this down because this is a
drug that's added to a prescription of
someone who's already taking any
depressants to prevent suicidal thoughts
or and but then one of the first side
effects they said to look out for it's
suicidal thoughts yeah what maybe
there'll be a third drug that people who
are already on antidepressants and
abilify can take for the suicidal
thoughts that abilify wasn't a
to get rid of from the original
antidepressant yeah maybe we're just
being cynical depression we just needed
trust in that cartoon lady with the
great voice
this is amnesia so loss I mean this is a
good example like we've all heard this
term evidence-based right yeah and the
idea is that conventional medicine is
evidence base and everything else is not
well that's total BS because this in
abilify is a great example it's an
anti-psychotic that's what it was
approved for for psychosis and yes we
have a lot of people yeah I mean recent
events indicate that we do have quite a
few psych psych psychotic people mass
shootings etc but not that many you know
not enough to make abilify that the
seventh leading drug on a sales basis
that since that's an insane number yeah
so what abilify is prescribed off-label
so off-label means a way of using the
drug that has never been a study or
approved by the FDA for that particular
purpose so it's using a drug in a way
that was not originally studied how is
that legal it's legal doctors have the
authority to prescribe medications
off-label as long as they're FDA
approved as long as they're FDA approved
for something that's insane vast
majority of abilify prescriptions
therefore are off-label which means
they've never been studied or shown to
be safe or effective for the conditions
that it's being prescribed for so your
doctor could legally prescribed you
birth control pills yeah I mean it would
be frowned upon and maybe if they did
that enough and it was causing problems
they would they would have to justify
why they were doing it but it's the
missing key to vilify for men okay you
have female birth control pills like it
means they can use it in a population
that hasn't been studied for so for
example a drug has been studied and
approved for adults did you see that it
said not safe you know it shouldn't be
used for children in the elderly yes
never been studied but that doesn't mean
it's not being prescribed for children
or the elderly it's still definitely is
but you know antidepressants have been
shown to cause to Inc suicidal ideation
in adolescents and teenagers in
particular and
they are still often used in that in
that group even though they were never
studied or approved for that population
what is this one Jamie a bill bill fires
top-selling year seven bits the
top-selling sorry stock sale usually
it's not the SAP number seven it's a
silly me is an anti-psychotic is that
real it's real but is it still the
top-selling drug whatever let's not even
look but in 2014 it was the top-selling
drug that is crazy has become the
best-selling drug in the United States
the alarms about the dangerous and
sometimes deadly side effects of
antipsychotics affecting children and
the elderly among others have been
mounting for years Wow that's terrifying
[Applause]
[Music]